if you're not proud of your business if
you're not proud of the people that you
help
if you're not proud of the things that
you do on a daily basis with your
company
then you're not going to be successful
your company will fail
hi i'm evan carmichael and i believe
that hungry entrepreneurs deserve
help and i see too many entrepreneurs
starting companies where they're not
really proud of what they're doing
they're not waking up happy with
themselves
if you're just trying to make the money
it's not going to come
you've got to have the passion for the
business and be proud
of what you're doing you should be able
to tell your friends and your family
with a lot of confidence
and pride that this is what you are
doing that you are helping people
you've got to be able to stand behind
your company if you're embarrassed to
talk about what you do
then you're in the wrong line of
business right now you're never going to
achieve success as an entrepreneur
richard branson like to say that he only
likes creating companies that he
believes in 100 percent
that he doesn't want to waste his time
waste his life
doing things that he is not proud of i
know what you're thinking
you know it's great to be proud about
what you're doing but proud doesn't pay
the bills
it's easy for someone like richard
branson to say that but how does it
apply to me
where i'm just struggling to get by and
that's the wrong line of thinking
because if you're desperate and you're
just trying to make money just to get by
then you're always going to be stuck
there
because you're going to take on business
opportunities that don't excite you
that don't speak to who you are that
don't truly help people
because they're just trying to make a
buck the guys who are just trying to
make a buck and are not part of their
businesses
don't make it big pride and being proud
of your company
does pay the bills it's the only thing
that pays the bills
you have to love what you do you have to
know that you're helping people
you have to feel it you have to get
excited about it
you have to wake up knowing that people
depend on you they rely on you
that their lives will be worse off
without you that if you don't get up and
go to work
they're going to be worse off for it you
have to feel that
you know when i'm making these videos
answering your questions
i feel the pain that you guys are going
through and i want to help
i get excited i usually do my videos on
a wednesday
wednesday is my favorite day of the week
because i get to talk to you guys
and make these videos to help i love
what i do i'm proud of it
i will proudly tell people about my
website but my youtube channel
all the things that i do and i've had
opportunities that seem great
to make a lot of money but i couldn't
stand behind it
i wouldn't feel proud telling you guys
telling my family about it
and so you say no even though it might
be hard because you look at the dollars
behind it
but if you want to have success if you
want to make the big money
then you have to be proud about your
business if you're not
you have to find something new if you're
just starting up a business you're
trying to grow your existing one
if you are not really happy with it if
you don't wake up every day proud about
what you're doing
switch focus it's possible it's not too
late to change
you can achieve rapid success rapid
success
when you can combine something that you
love doing
that you're really proud of and that
helps a lot of people
i really hope you'll apply it to your
business good luck
for those of you watching if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it makes me want to do more of
these videos for you
and i'd love to hear what you have to
think if you want to leave a comment
under the video or if you have a
question for your business
please leave it below i always read
those i really do love seeing them come
in so thank you
and i'll see you on the next episode